Aquí tenemos dos cilindros, y digamos que
sabemos que tienen exactamente el mismo volumen,
esto tiene sentido porque parece que tienen la
misma área en su base y tienen la misma altura.
Ahora, lo que voy a hacer es comenzar a cortar
este cilindro izquierdo aquí y mover un poco
las cosas. Si lo corto en dos y tomo este
cilindro inferior -esa mitad inferior- y lo
desplazo un poco, ¿habré cambiado su volumen?
Bueno, claramente no he cambiado su volumen,
todavía tiene el mismo volumen; podemos decir
que el volumen combinado de estas dos mitades
del cilindro es igual al del cilindro original.
¿Y qué pasaría si lo cortara aún más? Déjenme
cortarlo ahora en tres. Una vez más no he cambiado
el volumen original, sigue siendo el mismo volumen
que el del original y sólo lo corté en tercios.
Si los desplazo un poco no estoy cambiando el
volumen, y podría seguir haciendo eso, podría
cortarlo en muchas secciones. Ten en cuenta
que esto todavía tiene el mismo volumen original,
sólo lo corté en muchas secciones, lo he cortado
horizontalmente y ahora sólo estoy moviendo las
cosas, pero eso no cambia el volumen y puedo
hacerlo muchas veces. Estas parecen algún tipo de
fichas de juego. Aquí tengo mi cilindro original,
y ahora lo he cortado horizontalmente en un montón
de estas secciones, o podría decirles fichas, pero
claramente tiene el mismo volumen combinado, puedo
desplazarlas un poco pero tiene el mismo volumen.
Y esto nos lleva a una conclusión interesante,
y en realidad es un principio conocido como el
Principio de Cavalieri que dice que: si tengo dos
figuras que tienen la misma altura y en cualquier
punto a lo largo de esa altura el área de la
sección transversal es la misma, entonces las
dos figuras tienen el mismo volumen. Ahora, ¿cómo
se aplica lo que acabo de decir a lo que está
sucediendo aquí? Bueno, claramente ambas figuras
tienen la misma altura y luego en cualquier punto
en donde haya hecho los cortes y en el mismo punto
en este cilindro original el área de la sección
transversal será la misma, porque tiene la misma
área que la base, en el caso de este cilindro,
y así cumple con el Principio de Cavalieri. Pero
el Principio de Cavalieri no es nada exótico,
viene directamente del sentido común. Puedo seguir
haciendo más cortes -como este-, y puedes ver
que tengo un cilindro inclinado de aspecto más
suave, pero tendrá el mismo volumen que nuestro
cilindro original; cuando lo muevo así, no está
cambiando el volumen. Y eso no es sólo cierto para
los cilindros, podría ser exactamente el mismo
argumento con alguna forma de prisma. Una vez más,
ambas figuras tienen el mismo volumen; podría
cortar por la mitad la figura izquierda y moverla
y eso no cambia su volumen, podría cortarlo aún
más y sigue sin cambiar su volumen. Entonces el
Principio de Cavalieri parece tener mucho sentido
intuitivo aquí. Si tengo dos figuras que tienen la
misma altura y en cualquier punto a lo largo de
esa altura el área de la sección transversal es
la misma en ambas, entonces las figuras tienen
el mismo volumen, así que estas figuras también
tienen el mismo volumen. Y podría hacerlo con
otras figuras interesantes como, por ejemplo,
una pirámide. Estas dos pirámides tienen el mismo
volumen, y si corto la pirámide izquierda a la
mitad de su altura y desplazo la parte inferior de
esta manera, no va a cambiar su volumen, y puedo
seguir haciendo esto con más y más recortes
porque estas figuras tienen la misma altura
y en cualquier punto de esa altura el área de la
sección transversal es la misma en ambas, por lo
que las dos figuras tienen el mismo volumen. Pero
una vez más esto es intuitivo, y podemos hacerlo
hasta tener una pirámide continua aquí que se ha
inclinado, entonces no importa cuánto la inclines,
ésta tendrá el mismo volumen que nuestra pirámide
original porque tiene la misma altura y el área
de la sección transversal en cualquier punto
de esa altura será la misma. Realmente podemos
hacer esto con cualquier figura. Ahora tenemos
estas esferas que tienen el mismo volumen,
podría cortar la esfera izquierda por la mitad,
a la mitad de su altura, y desplazarla así;
claramente no estoy cambiando el volumen,
y podría hacer más cortes así, y obviamente
todavía tiene el mismo volumen. Esto cumple con
el Principio de Cavalieri porque tiene la misma
altura y la sección transversal en cualquier
punto a lo largo de esa altura será la misma,
entonces, aunque puedo cortarla y puedo deformarla
de manera que parezca un tipo diferente de objeto,
una figura distinta, tiene la misma altura y
las secciones transversales en cualquier punto
tienen la misma área, entonces tendrán el mismo
volumen. Esto es útil conocerlo, no sólo para
aprender el Principio sino para que, con la ayuda
de este video, veas que es bastante intuitivo.